in this video I want to help you gain an
intuitive understanding of calculus and
the derivatives now maybe you're
thinking that you haven't seen calculus
since your college days and depending on
when you graduate maybe that was quite
some time back now if that's what you're
thinking don't worry you don't need a
deep understanding of calculus in order
to apply new networks and deep learning
very effectively so if you're watching
this video or some of the later videos
be wondering wow this stuff really for
me this calculus looks really
complicated my advice to you is the
following which is that watch the videos
and then if you could do the homework
and complete the programming homework
successfully then you can apply deep
learning in fact what you see later is
that in week 4 will define a couple of
types of functions that will enable you
to encapsulate everything that needs to
be done with respect to calculus that
these functions call forward functions
and backward functions that you learn
about the less you put everything you
need to know about counselors into these
functions so that you don't need to
worry about them anymore beyond that but
I thought that in this foray into deep
learning that this week we should open
up the box and peer a little bit further
into the details of calculus but really
all you need is an intuitive
understanding of this in order to build
and successfully apply these algorithms
oh and finally if you are among that
maybe smaller group of people that are
expert in calculus if you're very
familiar with calculus observe this it's
probably okay for you to skip this video
but for everyone else let's dive in and
try to get an intuitive understanding of
derivatives I've plotted here the
function f of a equals 3/8 so it's just
a straight line to gain intuition about
derivatives let's look at a few points
on this function let's say that a is
equal to 2 in that case f of a which is
equal to 3 times 8 is equal to 6 so if a
is equal to 2 then you know F of a will
be equal to 6 let's say we give the
value of a you know just a little bit of
a nudge I'm going to just bump up me a
little bit so there is now 2.00 1 right
so I'm going to get a like a tiny little
nudge to the right so now is let's say 2
oh one this plug this is to scale 2.01
the 0.001 difference is too small to
show on this plot this give them a
little nudge to the right now F of a is
equal to three times at so six point
zero zero three Simplot this over here
this is not the scale this is six point
zero zero three so if you look at this
little triangle here some highlighting
in green what we see is that if I match
a 0.001 to the right then F of a goes up
by 0.03 the amount that F of a went up
is three times as big as the amount that
I judged a to the right so we're going
to say that the slope of the derivative
of the function f of a at a equals two
or when a is equal to 2 the slope this
reading and you know the term derivative
basically means slope is just that
derivative sound like a scary a more
intimidating word whereas slope is a
friendlier way to describe the concept
of derivative so one of these year
derivative just think slope of the
function and more formally the slope is
defined as the height divided by the
width of this little triangle that we
have in green so this is you know 0.03
over 0.01 and the fact that the slope is
equal to 3 or the derivative is equal to
3 just represents the fact that when you
watch a to the right by 0.01 by tiny
amount the amount that F of a goes up is
three times as big as the amount that
United the inertial a in the horizontal
direction so that's all that the slope
of a line is now let's look at this
function at a different point let's say
that a is now equal to 5
in that case F of a 3 times a is equal
to 15 so let's say I again give a and
notch to the right a tiny longnecks is
now
bumped up to 5 point over 1 F of a is 3
times that
so f of a is equal to 15 point zero 3
and so once again when I bump into the
right not a to the right by 0.001
F of a goes up three times as much
so the slope again at a equals five is
also three so the way we write is that
the slope of the function f is equal to
three we say D F of a da and this just
means the slope of the function f of a
when you nudge the variable a a tiny
little amount um this is equal to three
and an alternative way to write this
derivative formula is as follows you can
also write this as d da of f of a so
whether you put the f of a on top of
whether you write it you know down here
it doesn't matter
but all those equation means is that if
I nudge a to the right a little bit
I expect F of a to go up by three times
as much as I not just the value of
little a now for this video I explained
derivatives talking about what happens
we nudge the variable a by 0.001 um if
you want the formal mathematical
definition of the derivatives
derivatives are defined with an even
smaller value of how much energy a to
the right so it's not open over 1 is not
0.001 is not 0.0 and so on 1 is sort of
even smaller than that and the formal
definition of derivative says what have
you nudge a to the right by an info
testable amount basically an infinite
infinitely tiny tiny amount if you do
that does f of a go up three times as
much as whatever was a tiny tiny tiny
amount that you now stay to the right so
that's actually the formal definition of
a derivative but for the purposes of our
intuitive understanding we're going to
talk about nudging a to the right by
this small amount 0.001 even if it's
0.001 isn't exactly you know tiny tiny
insa testable now one property of the
derivative is that no matter where you
take the slope of this function it is
equal to 3 whether a is equal to 2 or a
is equal to 5 the slope of this function
is equal to 3 meaning that whatever is
the value of a if you increase it by
0.001 that
value of f of a goes up by three times
as much so this function has the same
slope everywhere and one way to see that
is that wherever you draw this your
little triangle right the height divided
by the width always has a ratio of three
to one so I hope this gives you a sense
of what the slope what the derivative of
the function means for a straight line
where in this example the slope of the
function was three everywhere in the
next video let's take a look at a
slightly more complex example where the
slopes of the function can be different
at different points on the function